yo what's up everybody prestige man
Luigi here with another ball runs per
sequel video and today we're gonna be
looking at an Easter egg I found within
the clap tastic way of GLC so to find
this we're gonna want to head to the
think tank which is located inside these
subconscious region of claptraps mind
you can fast travel to there and just
follow my path to where to get to it at
the thing tank is where you get the
mission the side mission temple of boom
if you guys have played that side
mission that'll give you some idea it's
kind of like it's a kind of like a big
fish bowl of water and there's little
Tannis fish and there's a little um I
forget is named the other doctor that's
in this game so you're just gonna it
also I must say it is a very simple
Easter Egg so there's not gonna be a
whole bunch of stuff to see in this
however I think it was pretty cool and I
haven't seen any videos about it so I
thought I'd make one so as you saw I
didn't go the main route over to the
left
I took a right when it split off in the
cap claptraps place there's gonna be
some enemies here you can run past them
or kill them I chose to kill them so I
just sped it up and when you kill them
just gonna head keep going straight go
up this staircase and you're gonna drop
down into the think tank and once you
get into the think tank if you hop a
left you'll see a big mechanical thing
it's in the sand that is actually the
head and the drill piece of a big Daddy
suit I think is what they were called
which were it was kind of like the face
of Bioshock if you've ever played or
seen Bioshock stuff so I thought this is
pretty cool fun little Easter egg and
throw a throwback to Bioshock hope you
guys have enjoyed this if you did make
sure you check out my channel for us to
stuff and yeah alright that's about it
I'll see you guys later in other pretty
cool vids or yeah peace out